hello again the top story and I'll just
see right this hour results are coming
in for it turkey is most tightly
contested election in decades there is a
dispute about the numbers with the Two
Front Runners both maintaining that
they're in the lead the anadolo
state-run news agency has reject on a
heads
unfortunately as in every election the
anadolu agency proved itself incompetent
and incapable once again but this will
change during our leadership we can no
longer talk about a credible and
reputable on a dollar agency when we
look at these results we can say that
our esteemed leader
kamalu will become the next president
frankly there is no point in arbitrarily
accusing the institutions if you have
been monitoring the results at the
polling stations you must have a
projection so quit accusing the
institutions we also received the
results from the polling stations but
most importantly the only thing that
matters is the official tally which will
provide a clear picture
okay so let's take a closer look at the
figures as they stand right now with
more than 90 percent of the votes
counted president has dropped just below
the 50 Mark in his main rival Kamal
kilis darulu has more than 44 and take a
look at the numbers in the Parliamentary
race that's where almost 90 percent of
the votes have been counted and it shows
that People's Alliance as a front-runner
with 50 of the votes on Nation Alliance
has received 35 percent
so in these high-stakes elections it's
worth taking a closer look at Turkey as
most important cities and provinces and
how they voted historically here's Alexi
O'Brien
Istanbul Ankara and Izmir are Tokyo's
three biggest cities and it said the
person who wins Istanbul wins the
country Tokyo's most populous province
is home to about 16 million people and
20 percent of all registered voters it's
where presidents Richard Thai Peruan
made his name as mayor but that job's
now held by the main opposition it's
also in control in Ankara the capital
and the coastal city of Izmir and the
last presidential election in 2018 all
of these provinces in yellow voted for
erdogan and turkey a central
conservative Heartland helping him stay
in power with more than half of the vote
but some of those strongholds in the
Southeast could now be in question with
these 11 provinces badly affected by the
earthquakes in February the head of the
Supreme election Council said that at
least one million voters there aren't
expected to cast their ballots because
they've been displaced by the disaster
let's head further south east where most
of the Kurdish population is
concentrated and the main pro-kurdish
party under the green left Banner has
thrown its support behind erdogan's
presidential rival Kamal Khalid the last
region to mention isn't even in Turkey
it's Western Europe where the vast
majority of the Turkish diaspora live
and its 3.4 million registered voters
about half of those have cast ballots in
this year's elections a record turnout
but some violence has been reported at
polling stations analysts suggest that
illustrates the polarization of the
Turkish electorate
all right let's begin hakana akbas he's
a political analyst he's joining us from
Istanbul welcome back to Al Jazeera sir
thanks for your time so here's where we
stand more than 90 percent of votes
counted I'm sure you're aware both men
the presidential contenders are below
that 50 threshold as of now how do you
expect the next few hours at least to be
playing out
well the Turkish Waters have spoken and
they are asking for change and both
candidates uh president erdogan as well
as the challengers
stand by for a moment I do apologize
because we're just going to cross over
to Ankara and listen to Kamal kalish
Earl glue speaking let's listen in
Council
we know that this is the case in 773
ballot boxes in Istanbul there are even
ballot boxes where six
concurrent objections have been made and
we know that this is the case across the
country
you cannot change the facts and you
cannot change the official results by
interfering in the elections by
submitting continuous objections and the
polling stations please stop interfering
with how donation perceives the results
of this elections
please stop manipulating the election
security so that the public knows the
real results and I also invite the
Supreme election Council to do their job
they have to
do
and follow the due process for the data
entry during the elections and I also
call or everyone in the nation who are
now working actively in polling stations
please do not quit the polling stations
until we get the official reports for
each Ballot Box thank you very much
you know okay so that is one of the
presidential contenders
he was just speaking in Ankara asking
people not to quit the polling stations
until the official results come through
let's once again bring in hakan akbas
he's a political analyst he's joining us
from Istanbul so uh are you surprised
that we heard from this political from
this presidential Contender at this
point
yes uh as expected uh this uh was going
to be a tight election and neither
candidate seems to have managed to uh
get to the 50 percent and especially the
votes in the large cities like Istanbul
and Ankara are being recounted and looks
like uh we may have a long night waiting
for us but the bottom line is though
because the third candidate seems to
have uh pulled over five percent and uh
so far it doesn't look like his numbers
will be changing it is looking uh very
likely that this will go into a runoff
vote in two weeks I do want to get onto
the subject of the third candidate in a
moment but first let me ask you about
the opposition and specifically the
parties with Kamal Kelly is right now
they're polling at
44.67 percent
um will they be disappointed with with
those numbers
yes absolutely because if you look at
the CHP kalista or those parties numbers
despite everything like the economic
difficulties turkey has been going
through despite the earthquakes and the
Damage afterwards the callistan all
those party has not been able to even
hit 30 percent so which says that it is
a disappointment for his party but more
importantly I think he seems to have
picked the wrong alliances because his
uh alliances as part of the Coalition of
six parties they've not been able to
even pull one percent combined unlike
erdogan's ruling Alliance they seem to
have done far better especially MHP the
Nationalist Coalition partner of erdogan
so for that purpose uh chpolo's own
party it seems to have done very poorly
and you were mentioning a moment ago one
of the big surprises a lot of people
seem to think is sinan Oran of the night
and so far he's he secured more than
five percent of the votes how do you
explain that and going forward how key
is his role going to be
great question I think tonight's winner
clearly is synonym and his basically uh
Coalition and this Alliance this this
election has been about nationalism and
nationalistic feeling of the voters and
um you know Cena no one seems to have
been able to get votes from both
alliances and also he seems to be really
doing better
thanks to president erdogan's campaign
uh going after pkk and trying to create
this perception of the opposition
Alliance really uh sort of being close
to the Kurdish party again allegedly now
um so Sinaloa looks like will be the
king makers in the second round and uh
he did say 24 hours before the election
that he would be sitting down and
negotiating with both alliances and we
know that President erdogan's party
especially after the mhp's strong
performance would have more to offer to
sinan oil in terms of a future because
cinnamon is a young candidate and he's
got a uh a bright future and if you look
at for example erdogan's Alliance
partner MHP uh the the current leader of
MHP is 75 years old so we may see that
erdogan's ruling Alliance may have more
to offer to sinanoa than the opposition
Alliance
okay we'll leave it there thank you so
much for speaking to us from Istanbul
let's not bring in Hashem he's joining
us from the headquarters of the
opposition CHP the Republican People's
Party in Ankara so Hashem we heard just
a few moments ago from Hashem are you
with us 300 boxes in Ankara 700 boxes in
Istanbul
all right I I don't think Hashem
can hear us we will